okay so let's get into our questions we
have a non from zoom the question is
given that the antibody titres seem to
reduce after 28 days um do you know if
the authors try to reinfect again after
a longer time frame has there been any
maybe you know since this is a bio
archives paper you know we often see
some changes over some time do you know
if maybe they started with a shorter
time frame and then it increased it and
then added some addition to it later on
is there any information around that yes
no I mean as Jeanne's noted often these
papers on bio archives are modified or
changed or added to before they get
finally published I do know that this
paper was updated once already and
actually some more monkeys were added to
the study so I would expect that this
lab is probably ongoing and is doing
these sorts of experiments now but they
haven't published that data yet so we
don't know the answer to those questions
yes be really interesting to see when
when they do okay well first of all that
was a really lovely way of explaining
immune memory I really enjoyed that
thank you Joe and we have another
question from Xun from one Wang who
wants to know if there's any data
showing what the lungs looked like right
before the reinfection that would be a
good question and to be honest if I was
reviewing this piece of work as a as a
peer reviewer it's probably something I
would ask the author's if they had and
if they could produce they did not
produce it in this particular experiment
so we're not sure about that if I was
speculating I would say that probably
the lungs had somewhat returned to
normal information like this can take
quite a while to go down right so it
wouldn't surprise me if they didn't look
perfectly normal but I would expect them
to certainly have modified from the
extreme sort of disease look that they
had in the middle of an infection so
I can also imagine that just you know
this is a primate research project which
is also a limiting factor so we have to
take that very seriously another
question and from Anissa on zoom' how
are the viral loads on the swabs
measured also the antibodies how are
they measured so maybe we could talk a
little bit about maybe the rt-pcr and
the antibody testing mechanism that our
colleague a Dallas Warren Pollard has
done a wonderful d4p talk on antibodies
and antibody testing so if you're really
interested in that I highly recommend
you check it out she's a wonderful
scientist how the how the virus is
detected is we look for its genetic
material and the genetic material that
you and I have is called DNA right
that's the form the genetic material
takes the virus produces genetic
material in a different form it's known
as RNA and what we do is we turn that
RNA into DNA we use an enzyme biological
machine to do that and then we use that
DNA because the converted DNA is easy
for us to work with and we basically
look for the presence of that we amplify
it we duplicate it and then look to see
if we can detect it so that's broadly
speaking how we look for the virus in
those swabs it's actually an extremely
sensitive technique the way that these
experiments are done and that's it's the
same kind of technology that underlies
detecting you know DNA the crime scene
right we're using this amplification
process to detect even really small
amounts of viral RNA to enable us to get
quite a good measure of how much virus
their walls in the lungs great okay so
we have another question now from
Caitlin who asks if the length of time
that immunoblot immunity lasts for one
strain of scarce co2 is different from
another strain errantly Caitlin has read
that some strains could affect people as
severely than others what do you think
about this
well so I want to be careful about using
the word strain and so scientists means
something quite precise when they talk
about different strains of a virus so
all the different copies of the virus
much like all the different people in
the world are slightly different
probably right because there are
mistakes made when duplicating when
copying the virus so new strains of a
virus are actually eat what that really
means is that it has a different sort of
disease progress right it's materially
different in terms of how the disease
progresses the properties of the disease
and I'm not actually that aware of their
being definitively different strains of
kovat 19 interested in in what Eugenie
and Pedro think about that so that's the
first thing that I say I think according
to a lot of the studies there there is
defended a lot of their viral
researchers studying this process right
now have demonstrated that there there
is probably only one strain but there
are obviously this is an RNA virus RNA
and viruses don't have checkpoints in
their polymerizes so the corona virus
family has a rudimentary proofreading
capacity in their earning race so that's
one of the reasons why the corona virus
genome is remarkably large compared to
other viruses but getting back to the
question of strains so I think the
consensus among researchers is that
there is a single strain but mutations
are occurring because mutations are very
natural and they they just occur and so
you can trace you know the movement of
the virus geographically by assessing
the tiny mutations that might exist
within a specific strain so I don't
think that there's any data to suggest
that any of these mutations are
different you know leading to a
different enough virus from the original
virus that started to infect humans and
that's really relevant because the
affinity for binding the east to
receptor I believe has not yet
been shown to be different among the
particles that demonstrate these tiny
little mutations that might be
associated with sort of the geographical
locations I hope that was clear and I'm
going to share an article that was
written by a fantastic journalist ed
young he describes this in more detail I
highly recommend that you follow ed
Young's coronavirus coverage it's really
excellent
I completely agree I love that young but
just also to that to the aspect of
immunity even if there are some
mutations found in the corona virus the
the immunity is generated as Jo explains
so well on the stickiness of these
antibodies that are going to bind the
proteins on the surface of the corona
virus and as far as I understand none of
these mutations has caused enough
difference in these proteins for them to
be recognized any differently and and I
think so we do have a question that is
not related to the paper but may be
related a little bit to this process and
so um why is it so hard to develop a
vaccine for a covent 19 right and so
there's currently no vaccine for the
2003 SARS and I wonder if that's because
it was contained and is now technically
extinct now I would add I would actually
counter by saying I think relatively
speaking now we don't know we're still
finding out stuff about this virus but
relatively speaking I would actually
speculate that this is a virus which it
probably will be possible probably will
be possible to generate a vaccine
against and that's actually I'm pretty
sure that's the opinion of Anthony found
she who's you know the top disease
expert infectious disease expert here in
the United States there are other
viruses like HIV for example which
scientists have been trying for decades
and decades to generate viruses against
and that's actually proved really
difficult so I think the answer to this
question really is about people's
expectations and timing there is a
wonderful article in The New York Times
which lays out the timeline for how
vaccines are usually developed and it
usually takes 20 30 40 years to develop
a vaccine against a virus and that's
usually no small part because of a
different sort of testing that we have
to do on anti-de on the on the vaccine
to make sure that it's safe to make sure
that it works and those tests take a
long time and the basic research to find
out what is the best version of the
virus or fragment of the virus to use in
the vaccine takes a long time so
actually I think what we're gonna see
probably in this case is a vaccine or
multiple different vaccine candidates
developed at breakneck speed relative to
how long vaccines usually take it's just
that this virus did really appear and
catch us flat-footed we hadn't done that
much research on this group of viruses
and we don't have those the progression
of those trials already happening we
have to start from from nowhere I also
want to clarify that my colleagues have
informed me that there was indeed a
vaccine that was developed for the
original SARS in 2003 and they stopped
making it because nobody was the virus
okay so next question from Danielle what
is it about different viruses that
causes variable time frames of memory x
expiration that's a really good question
so for examples the example you gave of
measles against influenza or or common
colds yeah this is a really good
question and I think the answer we know
some reasons why this might happen but
we probably don't have the full picture
yet as scientists so if I think about
some of the things that we think about
and we think of as impacting how well
your immune system remember something
usually people who have more severe
disease and have you know maybe they're
really debilitatingly ill with the
disease will remember that disease
better than someone who is only mildly
sick so there is seems to be some
correlation between how sick you get and
how well your immune system is going to
remember it also may depend on the
amount
virus that your pathogen you're exposed
to at the beginning and there are lots
of other things that probably we don't
know some viruses so flu is a really
interesting virus there's actually
multiple different types of flu and
multiple different strains of flu and so
we think of flu as being a capsule term
but really when you get through the next
year it's not really this it's not
actually the same virus that's infecting
you for a second time it's probably a
different strain of of the virus so flu
is very difficult to contain and could
remember for your immune system because
it's basically like someone that keeps
changing their clothes right your immune
system has to recognize this person and
if thought oh okay I remember this
person they were wearing in a red pants
and a blue shirt and then through comes
in the next time and it's wearing a
yellow shirt and green pants and your
system has to recognize it again and
basically has to relearn everything
again so that's why flu particularly is
not very well remembered now I think
that that also answers one of the
questions we had from Ottavia around
what makes what makes a virus more
memorable right and and so it's it's
really tricky and I think our colleague
at Rockefeller Jean Laura Casanova talks
about host factors so the factors that
we contain genetic differences in our
bodies that could also you know dictate
the our immune memory or our immune
responses in general and so all of this
is is really just an amazing I think
it's still kind of like a mystery for
many scientists out there it's the
million-dollar question and I think the
corona virus the kovat 19 situation that
we're currently in right now is
definitely driving the research on a lot
of these questions in ways that we've
never seen before so I think a lot of
this might come out in the future I mean
there at least I I feel I feel positive
that we are gonna make a lot of us in
these areas given the amount of tension
it's being provided um so let's talk we
have a question for another question
from one about the
the livelihood of the monkeys regarding
did monkeys one in two pass away or
where they just used as a control why
weren't they not reinfected I'm so the
second part of your question where the
uses that can you use as a control
that's really important so they
definitely scientists definitely need
that so if you're going to make a
comment about how the monkey responded
to reinfection you need to be able to
compare it to a monkey that was not
reinfected and the reason for that is
let's say you reinfected the monkey 28
days after the first infection it's
possible that there was just a delayed
response which took 28 days and is gonna
only gonna crop up after it's only going
to appear after you've done the second
infection and you might then wrongly
attribute that that response to the
reinfection when actually it was just a
delayed response from the first
infection so it's very important to have
controls and certainly that's true of
the monkeys that were only infected once
um in answer to the the overall like
livelihood of the monkeys um there were
definitely unfortunately monkeys which
which died in the course of this
experiment and that I kind of you know
try to give an outline of the sorts of
considerations that are given to an
experiment like this even being allowed
to happen in the first place and there
will have been a good number I can't
speak to the process of the particular
institution where this paper was done I
know it's an accredited institution but
at Rockefeller you know there's a panel
which consists of veterinarians and it
has outside people who are not
affiliated with the University on it you
have to approve every animal experiment
that's done and sign off on it and say
this is acceptable and you know we use
those ours for three hours to guide us
in our use of animals and we only choose
to use an animal like a monkey when it
really really is necessary for advancing
the science I don't know if Pedro or
Jeanie have any anything
I think that's pretty much covers a lot
of my forties around this I have not
ever worked in a primate lab myself but
I do know people think extremely
seriously this is not a you know these
are very carefully planned and
scientists go to extreme measures to
make sure they're using the fewest
amount of animals possible to get the
results that are rigorous and applicable
to whatever disease it is that they need
to work for example the Koba 19 disease
right and so these are these are hard
questions and I think that I appreciate
that people are exploring exploring this
year because we are we are in a
situation where you know we can't take
humans and and and reinfect them to see
what happened well there are people who
are signing up for this kind of stuff so
it's just it's a difficult it's a
difficult decision that we have to make
yeah then it's you know you you you
study the disease at as it goes in
hospitals and with the patients you have
access to but obviously that's not the
same thing as having everything
controlled in a time controlled manner
in a laboratory setting which you do
with monkeys which you you know
obviously have to reduce to the minimum
possible amount but that actually lead
us leads us very nicely into our next
question from the wake who wants to know
whether the lung biopsies that you
showed were where biopsies or were
post-mortem slides and also what your
view is on the monkey immune response as
compared to the human immune response to
different strains of code at 19 yeah
so that second part is of consideration
that every single biologist is boring at
night about about whether their
particular animal is the same as a human
for example but let me address the first
one first so those were post-mortem
slides done after an autopsy on the
monkey and but the second part we
respect you how similar is a monkey's
immune system to a human I mean the
reason this experiment was done on
monkeys is because monkeys have the most
similar immune system to humans and so
in a situation like this where we have
an extremely important time sensitive
question about a pandemic that's killed
hundreds of thousands of people we want
to get an answer which is translatable
to humans as quickly as possible
analyst answer with a high degree of
certainty as possible and so that's why
we would use a monkey in this situation
they do have the most in renewing system
to humans of other animals that we could
use so I would say it's sort of we hope
that there's hope we know that they are
extremely similar there will be some
modest differences and we do our best to
work those out and apply what's learned
in monkeys to humans with you know
enough modesty that we don't think we
know all the answers and we acknowledge
that it is possible but it would behave
slightly differently in a human so we
have a very smart question from Aaron
around immunological memory so going
back to that aspect and Joe if or if
anybody else on the panel of scientists
are here and maybe you would chime in if
Joe this might be outside of your area
of expertise so in terms of the immune
systems memory is this related to how
past pathogens mutate for example is the
reason our immune systems don't remember
the common cold infections but do
remember measles infections because the
cold virus mutates a lot more quickly
but the the measles virus does not and
how quickly is the novel coronavirus
mutating relative to other viruses in
our immune system okay so the answer to
the first part about whether memory is
related to mutation it definitely is
related to mutation but it's that's also
not the full story so for example HIV is
a virus which is extremely promiscuous
in how it replicates itself and as a
result it makes lots of mistakes and
mutates a huge amount and that's why
it's it's very difficult for your immune
system to respond to it and I was just
talking about flu and I use the analogy
of the flu sort of changing clothes
every year and making a difficulty or
mune system to recognize it so that
definitely has a role in shaping how
well a particular pathogen is remembered
but I do also want to say that I it
doesn't explain it all right there are
definitely pathogens which for whatever
reasons seem to elicit extremely strong
immune responses in certain people and
be remembered extremely well and other
pathogens which may be a less easy to
remember and that might also be to do
with how sort of sticky the pathogens
are right so if you have a pathogen
which is extremely sticky and it's very
easy to make antibodies which will stick
extremely well to it maybe it will be
remembered very well but if you have an
antidote if you have a pathogen which is
a bit slippery and it's quite hard to
stick to that one might be remembered
less well I don't know if other people
and they're definitely people on this
panel who know more about this than me
but I don't know if any of them have oh
sorry in response to the second bit I
think Jeanne already mentioned this the
the corona virus actually relative to
other viruses which are RNA viruses it
mutates quite slowly and that's because
it has this ability to check how whether
it's doing a good job in record check
the fidelity of its copying of its
genetic information so when it's
duplicating its genetic information if
it makes a mistake there is a machine
piece of machinery which can say no
you've made a mistake
drop that bit out and redo it and other
RNA viruses don't have that so they make
spelling mistakes when they're
replicating that you know more often so
relatively to those viruses it retakes
less quickly oh well thank you we do
have another question from an anonymous
attendee which speaks a little bit to
what we were discussing earlier about
experiments with macaques and the
differences from from humans and they
asked if you
know whether the monkeys were all
hanging out together for this experiment
meaning where the monkeys separated and
would this have an effect on how sick
the monkeys got or how effectively they
became a new I mean I think this is a
fantastic question because one of the
other things it gets at is you know one
of the problems with this disease is if
you you can't treat all people as
individuals people associate in groups
for example in a family unit right so
it's quite likely that if one of those
people in those family unit gets
infected it's going to spread around to
other people so they're definitely
dynamics that come into play when you
start thinking about how met organisms
or humans or monkeys grouped together I
can tell you in this experiment the
monkeys would not have been allowed to
be in a group together because if one of
the monkeys gets better we don't want it
to confound the experiment by
reinfecting by being reinfected by one
of the other ones which is still sick
and so they will be housed separately
and in monkey kind of housing they
usually have you know they have toys
they have mirrors they have things like
that which it's called enrichment
basically to make the monkey happy and
give it stuff to do and so that's the
sort of conditions under which set
they're usually housed but again I'm not
actually I don't even work with any
animals in the lab I only work with
cells in Petri dishes so this is really
not i'm sending on a primate researcher
thanks Jim
okay so we're gonna take one final
question because we are at one hour and
15 minutes but the conversations have
been so wonderful that we were reluctant
to close it down after an hour and we
are gonna end with our question from
Aditi ID do you have asked a question at
every single d4p so thank you very much
I hope you're well it's so nice to see
you on here so Aditi was one of our s
SRP students so that's exciting that
you're joining us here okay this is a
fantastic question around male-female
differences in Hoorn potential role of
hormones and so as the research in the
the female immune system is better than
fighting the outbreak due to differences
in hormone levels I'm not sure if the
research has indicated I know that
females tend to get kovat 19 at a lower
frequency than males but it's not clear
that's due to hormone so I just want to
throw that out there but I love the way
that you're thinking here what do you
know if hormones play any role in immune
memory so this is totally over my head I
do not but I would let me make one
comment which is that in relation to you
know this hormone question it's very
difficult to tease out the different
parts of what's having an impact in
science particularly in human
experiments because we know for example
that men smoke more often than women and
smoking is obviously going to be pretty
bad for your lungs and it's it's a risk
factor for having a worse prognosis if
you get a respiratory disease so seeing
that men get getting a particular
disease worse and have worse outcomes as
a result of it might be to do with
biological variation caused by in
hormones or it could be to do with other
things which also are to do with being
male right so if men smoked at a high
rate then really what's what's happening
is it's not that being male is causing
you to develop kovat worse it's that
smoking is causing you to develop Kovach
work and smoking as a factor correlates
with sex somehow so we have to be very
careful when thinking about those things
I personally do not know anything about
hormones and their impacts on the immune
system but I don't know if one of the
other panelists can shed some light on
that
Ian ology is definitely over my head I'm
just a plain old geneticist so I think I
think Jo what you've raised here is sort
of like the that the problems that we
face in the lab or in clinical studies
in the field
is you know it's really hard to boil
something down to a single reason right
um yeah and so they're so it's
multifactorial
and I think there's gonna be many years
of research being done to really fully
give us any kind of a picture moving
forward and it's you know dr. Pollard
who's on here is just texting us to tell
us it's really hard to tease out
hormones and their impact on the immune
system
and yeah so it's it's it's a hard
question and I but I I appreciate that
people are thinking in that direction
because I think we have to keep thinking
right and so good job on that